et comme promis on va continuer à
voyager en argentine maintenant avec le
départ du dakar 373 concurrents un tiers
de moins que l'an dernier s'apprête à
prendre la route
au programme 9 min km de pistes à
travers la cordillère des andes sur
place julien benedetto régis mater il y
a toujours un peu de tango et beaucoup
de football dans le coeur des argentins
mais au pays de maradona et messi
on vibre aussi pour le tac à se changer
c'est pour le dakar le jour se lève à
peine dans la capitale argentine
et déjà on se pressent par milliers au
grand départ pour découvrir le plus
grand musée de sport automobile à ciel
ouvert 550 bolides et leurs carrosseries
rutilantes force ici l'admiration
ces engins dégage une telle puissance
les voir ici dans notre pays c'est
vraiment très émouvant
c'est très impressionnant et ça me rend
vraiment heureuse de voir le real ici en
argentine
je ne voulais pas rater ça et voilà ce
qui attend les concurrents avides
aventure un périple piégeux de 9000
kilomètres qui sait la part belle aux
montagnes de sable du désert d'atacama
au chili avec dans le rétroviseur
les sims enneigés de la cordillère des
andes c'est un rêve déjà quasiment
d'enfants j'ai toujours voulu participer
à cette épreuve et je crois que dans ce
cadre là ça va être une merveille
j'espère aller au bout on sait que ça va
être hyper dur mais on ne va quand même
mais bon on est pris pour pour quelques
galères à venir mais bon entre le
paysage les spectateurs sur la piste
c'est serait génial malgré l'immense
succès populaire d'une à car ici en
argentine
on attend 500 mille spectateurs pour le
grand départ l'organisation envisage dès
l'année prochaine un retour sur le sol
africain